was nothing but Stewie
it's a very very Star Wars I am Doug
Walker with me is the guy who made the
Kessel run in less than 12 parsecs doing
Kevin Spacey doing Christopher Walken
it's multiple on Thursday Night Live
okay Malcolm and rays biggest fan Tamara
come on Kyle Oh Jimmer's I'm Darth dad
oh I will go with dad Vader but so Cara
Lee was Brad's dream come true to say
these lines yeah to say I know your
family's wig I know it's an important
day like he said yeah do I get to say
any lines I'm like you get to say these
lines he's like oh good those are the
ones I've always wanted to say and that
the fight thing is that this is some
people were saying do you ever think
about doing a crossover with Chris
Stockman and we're saying this actually
was gonna be a crisis Brad was gonna be
in it as well but he was probably just
gonna be is you're gonna be a three-way
review or he was just gonna be so low in
the reenactments because we knew as
Harris before was so good but then
stuckman something else came up and he
apologized a million times I'm sorry I'm
sorry I can and I got Christmas with
family and I got this thing with the
screen junkies and stuff I'm like it's
really okay I mean it's don't worry
about we'll find something else so we we
call Brad in and we just made it I felt
like it had to be a crossover because
there just had to be somebody to throw
these ideas off of and of course yes we
can't do without it being a Star Wars
Hanukkah special which I love is people
say in the comments if anyone hasn't
seen the holiday special this is the
weirdest ass shit in here Brad nasty
shit he every single time we film this
he just could not stop laughs Mike you
know he's already big laugher but it's
like something about this like he could
not control himself he's like just he's
deaf it's ending he was sending pictures
of it all his friends he was filming at
us falling like he probably watches
before he goes to sleep she's like oh my
god I'm gonna have that be my ringtone
it's always fun with Branson ya know
he's always like just the nicest guy
well we were all riding the hi having
just seen the film too so Brad and I
were talking about it all day well in
the the fight thing this is probably
this might be the fastest I've written a
review especially a clipless review cuz
I had to do it the day after it came out
you know we still have Thursday night
you know opening night and then spoilers
yeah we saw a Thursday night and then
like we had to I just had to ride this
super fast because there were so many
props for it and we knew we had we
already got some Star Wars ships to be
safe and everything but it's like
there's a lot to set up for this so I
just had to write it super super fast
and it actually came out pretty good it
came out okay your view of the film is
soften well that's always the fun thing
too is that I mean now the you know
that's just repeating Star Wars in the
past I mean that's just been done to
death now so it's one of those things
where it's like you know if I could go
back I don't know if I make as big a
deal about it but again it's showing the
importance of it
mouthing I love this sideways gun you do
hear the 90s style stormtrooper West
Side Ted remember Tony I was like you
know I look nothing like you could
barely bend your arms I remember when we
should fight you were every single
stormtrooper yeah so if you ever see a
couple running by what I mean that we
just had to shoot him like four five
just like furio's
10 was like that's amazing that's
awesome I want this oh my god you guys
see I love this stuff I love just
summing up really fast what's happening
in the movie you know cuz it reminds me
kind of those you know one-minute movies
with bunnies you know just when you
really look at it like summed up in a
fast way it's like yeah this is a little
weird actually the drunkest pilots I
really wanted to get all of them as
models all the ships but I just didn't
have the time so I had to go and get a
few CG the animated version yeah so this
is why it's like wait why does Brad
actually put himself in the review
because it's like he was mainly just
gonna be so rich but then I like the
idea I'm air I saw that at Target and I
just told Jim I'm like I found our
Chewbacca and that's John Claude Van
Dam's green screen so the bantha Pudu
that was what a chocolate cake yeah
chocolate cake and a brownie mix in oil
your fare how you think my foot feels
wow they're you know dad's great at
making shit great and putting shit
together oh and here's KJ's great I get
if nobody seen the holiday special they
would have no idea no we did a couple I
said you know do one where you're doing
and why said we did a couple different
version we said do what like the actual
you know like the holiday especially I
said go a little bit more over-the-top
sexy you know Sarah did that and I said
okay now just go insane batshit insane
and I just ended them all together they
came out amazing this killed me when I I
had to do the sound yet again and I got
so I got to see these kind of dailies in
this whole South Park animation the
editor and just laughing the only one
that was so excited to see their giant
and that's so pissed off whether you saw
it flicker a hologram it's like oh no no
most amazing Theory effort it's like
watch now when they finally encounter
he's like the size of Yoda amazing
that'd be okay if they did that no I he
was one of the weaker things I love the
movie but I was like yeah that was weak
I have no idea what I'm doing Doug just
fed me the line I want to show yeah it's
very Saddam Hussein so you know the two
things I've always amazed by is Malcolm
when you do your devil boys I've always
liked God I forget how cool that is and
then Tamara when you do your British
boys I'm always like God she does that
so well and we'll talk more about it
right after this
then we're back and I should point out
Tamra did this review without seeing the
movie share that scene again I'm like
well we pretty much ruined everything
couple things back there there there's
Robin the dinosaur well technically
that's mondongo be Jedi captain he'll
look more like Bea Arthur saddest well
then this line about the MarySue cuz
when Wells writing it that wasn't a
thing yet and then it started becoming a
Mary Sue is she not so I feel like
that's max landis made a fool of himself
and novels in the internet went nuts
that's in our great little cartoon
actually doing kylo Ren was fun I got to
do that voice
yeah that's originally I did if I was
like you were ready to learn specific
kind of max yeah but I didn't know
whether or not to kill of them this
Cantina his Johnny Walker
oh here's the other guys okay Brad just
kept dying over like Rob's on this open
every time you walk on yeah we're
dressed like this is my new favorite
character I totally want to know this
guy's backstory you should do a whole
review based around him like what all
right this is my favorite fact in the
whole thing cuz these two they're in the
same room but Tamra is on the floor cuz
we couldn't get this thing up and Jim is
standing up so they are nowhere near
each other and yet they act like the
right next to each other because she's
basically duct-taped to a minivan but
she's actually sitting on the ground
like cuz it's just a seat and then this
this scene killed me this belongs in an
older brothers belongs in a museum so
dunno this took very little editing
because you guys were
so well off each other and just the
speed and how fast it's a neighbor movie
I guess I mean those responses I want to
assign this okay and wear this all right
and I do that why not you know it's just
I know you like the Mad Max review
morning I like the artistry that went
into that more because we built all the
models and stuff but when it comes to
the best put together review I out of
the clip list I think this one's the
best it is very good the pacing
everything it goes at a nice quick bit I
feel like everything just clicked it
worked perfectly
so the Brad's line there was actually a
meme I posted after I saw great shot kid
that was one in the billion I said that
was my react to the film and those who
had seen it I really liked I see what
you did there
those who had just thought i'ma say in
the movie was good
Jim Europe and again some people are
like well what's they're saying about
the movie you know what where's the
commentary on it and it's it's building
up how friggin obvious Han Solo's
depends even though it's yeah it works
it's still emotional but it's like you
could see this from a mile away and so
you said you know how is your father Han
Solo it's like you know he's dead well I
did but I didn't know if they were gonna
do it in this one we were saving for the
second
no no MLK I'm not kidding
the line I love you and kylo Ren saying
I know I wanted that to be in the movie
would that be amazing if that was in the
movie I took a picture this incented to
my wife and she's like I don't even want
to know
yeah we had to do it somebody takes on
that I'm like really this is the take
that's take you forever to do it say you
oh yeah whip stir whip whip wha whatever
and it's like no needs to be exactly one
point two three seconds a perfect to me
details in like it's like now it's a
little too early that's difficult is fun
that's be the Six Day why do you think I
mean how many times have I played that
clip and that scene is like you would
think you would have it wo wait for mr.
word wha
it's like no shorter that stay with
whips stay with wha as I know you need
stir whip stir whip whip whip stir wha
the cow standing there and I know I'm
right I'm like no one would have given a
shit oh yeah I give a shit maybe too
busy complaining about the fan that's
clipless I didn't notice
Rob Rob Rob I care it's one of your
friend even cares about yeah this is
like and this is just watching it again
it is much better the second time
everybody's right it is Brad and I were
talking about that sword fight it's like
I really wish there was something else
that's the one thing I wish I love was
horsing with the x-wing battle was the
thing that didn't us yeah but no Brad
and I were talking about he's like this
he's like oh my god there's reasons not
to like this movie but half of what I'm
season was whiny sissy pansy fanboy
bullshit that I've ever seen
he was like going on a rant about it
well I think cuz he just got done
watching like the road chip is you dare
call force awakens a force awakens it's
garbage it's like you don't know what
fuckin garbage get out of here I
actually never knows how much bb8 are
two words similar with the actual but
they had the exact same kind of eye
button and mal button but oh no it was
just interesting I didn't know it's just
an updated version of that type Android
that makes sense like yeah baby the real
one
oh okay here's the funny thing so we
shot the bb-8 we're trying to control
this thing because it's a phone app how
you control eyes okay I just want to go
left right back and forth and then just
sort of be in front of the camera and
look around and we're trying to control
it to do it and it's just not paying
attention it's just not we're having
such a hard time doing it and we're like
okay you know what there's an AI setting
that just lets it do whatever it wants
try that we pushed this button
it literally stops right in the middle
the camera right in frame does
everything I wanted it to do in under a
minute and I'm like that's it yeah it
was actually a better actor than we
could have hopefully yeah yeah yeah and
then he realized the camera was off then
like beep senses would you also like me
to wink that's the day the machines okay
I go charger but again with these
especially with the clipless reveal like
there has to be an angle to it like the
hanukkah special was the angle to this
the app was the what was the reason we
went with a Chanukah special it's
because CollegeHumor did yeah
CollegeHumor did a Christmas special -
yeah they you know Christmas special
with the new movie and so well shit that
was our idea and now it was gonna say
we're ripping it off and everything what
are we gonna do
and I literally just text it to you rob
I said Star Wars the Chanukah special
and you just called me up Ellesmere
Esther you just call me up in me a he's
like are you fucking kidding think about
it Chuy's family can be Jewish Jewish
and that's what I said fine but only if
we have Bea Arthur saying anti Jedi
but I thought of B Arthur singing anti
Java it was suddenly aboard yeah that
was my initial point is that can you out
of your mind
I remember what we're doing the last
song sequence here cuz you never saw the
holidays budget right Tamara so we were
explaining this scene and Brad just
explains to the best yeah so Carrie
Fisher gets up coked out of her ass
speeds
total gibberish
and then proceeds to sing this song
having no idea what she's saying
surrounded by all these Chuy's ten times
her size and then she says this is for
The Tree of Life and you got pretty good
and then somewhere we just I did write
in the script you're like family to me
but Brad really wanted to put it in
there we're trying to figure out where
to put it in so literally it's the last
thing we're gonna shoot is us touching
the ball in France it can I just say it
here and I'm like sure the volume a
brand also made a special note to get
the disinterested look that Harrison
Ford had during the end song yeah there
that one he's not happy he's not
discussed he's just so disinterested you
know what I've seen too much Steven
universe because I want to say oh my god
yeah no that's it's actually my new
favorite it was a rush but turned out
really nice cuckoo we'll see you at the
next Star Wars Holiday Special
oh wait we gotta yeah then I forgot like
oh wait we had to announce the month
let's just have a where's he still hit
it did give us the greatest Twitter
account ever lonely Luke wait did I
leave our to a little power mode shit
we will talk to you later bye bye oh
yeah this is improv that I had to leave
it it
it stupid mutt Williams this is why we
love we're here with Brad